[Music]
in the cartoon world flushing an
airplane toilet would mean that the
waste would come flying down and
probably land on an unfortunate person
but today we'll explain what happens
when you flush an airplane toilet at
least for the majority of the time stay
tuned to find out what actually happens
when things go wrong if you're new here
hit that subscribe button to never miss
another video and don't forget to give
us a big thumbs up let's check out what
actually happens when you flush an
airplane toilets pneumatic vacuum you
probably notice that the sound of a
toilet being flushed on a plane is
slightly louder than a regular flush
sound okay
maybe not just slightly louder it's
sometimes so loud it leaves us wondering
if everyone else on the plane can hear
us flush the toilet and gives us some
serious snakes on the plane flashbacks
don't worry there are no snakes on most
of the planes but there is another
reason why airplane toilets make such
loud sounds the sound is why people
often assume that the remain simply gets
somehow released in the sky but that's
not exactly true after you flush the
toilet the waste gets exposed to a
pneumatic vacuum which is air operated
and designed for environments where
electricity is not largely available so
when the toilet valve opens up the
vacuum takes care of every content into
a closed waste system which is connected
to a tank after the plane lands and once
the tank is full its emptied out by a
ground crew the exterior latch you might
see on a plane helps to keep the load
secure and make sure the pilot doesn't
accidentally press a button that would
drop the entire tank midair sounds like
a mess free and organized process right
well it wasn't always this way in fact
the system came a long way from the
early days did you know that these new
systems were invented in 1975 and first
installed in 1982 stay tuned to hear
about some messy accidents but first
let's take a look at the history of
airplane toilets and what people had to
do to go number two before the vacuums
were created hey guys we are so excited
to announce we're pretty
our own original content head over to
the trendy for the best DIYs fashion
tips makeup hacks and so much more we
are sure you're going to love it and be
sure to let us know what you think in
the comment section you lefty hear from
you see you there the history this
system changed over the years and
airplanes during the mid-1980s had to
carry large amounts of an attack the
blue deodorizing liquid that helped push
the waste from the toilet into onboard
storage tanks the planes required so
much an attack that they had to increase
their fuel consumption and reduce the
number of passengers during flights it
doesn't make sense right the anatec also
included so much bleach it irritated
people's skin and even eyes what's even
worse is that the early systems were
prone to leaking which meant the waste
would actually drop from the sky once
the plane landed while this still
happens it's definitely not as bad as it
was in the early days if you think about
it the 1980s aren't that far away which
means people from centuries ago had to
rely on other aviation toilet using
methods for example Second World War
pilots often had to use a bucket as
there was no other option available at
the time this would also mean that any
kind of turbulences or unusual
occurrences could easily result in an
unpleasant and very smelly experience
inside the aircraft an airman once
described the experience as Devils
convenience and said it shared its
content with the floor the walls and
even the ceiling during shaky times he
also reported that the container was
prone to overflow during long flights
and we're pretty sure you can get the
picture of how messy that might have
looked it's been reported that pilots
sometimes also through the full bucket
on their targets which can be noted as
biological warfare but overall it sounds
like airplane toilets had a long
historical journey the old days
definitely weren't fun
Henry glide technology allows us to use
modern airplane toilets we can really
count ourselves lucky well at least some
of us can check out these very
unfortunate situations of people getting
the short end of the airplane stick
blue-ice damages have you ever heard the
reports of blue ice falling from the sky
blue ice occurs when that
blew deodorizing liquid from an airplane
toilet leaks into the sky and freezes at
high altitude you'd be surprised by just
how destructive airplane toilet waste
can be between 1979 and 2003 27 blue-ice
accidents were reported and some were
even so strong they smashed cars
although no fatality was ever officially
reported the smelly but powerful
incidents alone were enough of a reason
for the airline industries to look into
a better solution stay tuned to hear
about some of the most unfortunate ways
the so called blue ice managed to hit
people around the world it's actually
more common than you might think a
series of unfortunate events
the pneumatic vacuums which made that
loud noise on a plane were first
invented in 1975
the very first versions of this system
were installed by Boeing in 1982 and
it's still the same to this day reports
of blue ice falling from the sky are no
longer relevant however there have been
several reports of toilet waste still
leaking and falling on unsuspecting
victims on the ground one such is a Salt
Lake resident who lives below the flight
path of the International Airport she
said she first thought it's a bird but
no it turned out to be a plane the same
happened at a very unfortunate sweet 16
birthday party where one team's garden
got covered in questionable feces
another frozen lump of toilet waste
managed to wreck a very expensive
caravan in England as it fell right
through the roof in 2012 a New York
couple got drenched in questionable
sludge in their back patio a woman from
India even suffered from injuries after
an ice ball which was the size of a
football fell from the sky however it
hasn't been discovered whether the ice
actually is blue ice as a result of an
airplane toilet leak but we can't
imagine that probably wasn't a pleasant
experience and in case you're wondering
you can actually get compensated if
you're ever hit by actual blue ice
although we really don't recommend
waiting for that moment to happen it
seems like the flying waste is much more
damaging than we ever thought it was and
that's it for our video for more videos
like this one make sure to check out 10
secrets flight attendants don't want you
to know see you
next time
[Music]